this report is is quite arranging it
makes a couple of recommendations but i
do wonder what's being said to the
social media companies to try and make
sure that they bring in these uh
warnings on images that they have been
doctored
well good morning kamali i mean the
truth is as you say in that report the
world has changed very dramatically we
now think that around 60 of 17 to 19
year olds may have a possible eating
disorder so this is a very
dramatic increase over the last couple
of decades
and social media appears to be one of
the causes we call for some research to
be done so that we can properly
understand that but at a very minimum
when commercial companies photoshop
images to make people look
more thin than they would be in real
life we think that should be labeled we
think people looking at those images
should know this is not a real human
being and that's part of the way that we
can help people use social media with
more awareness of some of the tricks of
the trade if you like and therefore stop
this this focus on ever thinner bodies
which is so damaging to so many young
people particularly young women
yeah i mean i mean you think that mr
hunter as you as you were saying i'm
sure many of our viewers feel the same
it does beg the question why is it
taking so long to try and make sure that
those kind of rules are brought into
place is it an issue with regulation
should there be legislation brought in
what's the holdup because we've known
about this for a while
well um in fairness i think that mps
have been on the case for quite a while
and my colleague dr luke evans has been
campaigning very hard on this in
parliament um and i think the social
media landscape
is in need of an overhaul in areas like
this particularly when it affects young
people
but i think the most important thing is
the message we're giving in this report
is just not the case that there's
nothing we can do about this there's the
doctored social media images there's
also the fact that you've got a lot of
backstreet cowboys where you can just
turn up and get uh non-surgical cosmetic
procedures done
to change the look of your face the
shape of your nose and we say that
shouldn't be something you can just turn
up and get done on the spot there should
be a cooling off period and in
particular there should be an obligation
on whoever is conducting that procedure
to look into your full history including
your mental health history and talk
about that with you because um it might
be that this isn't actually anything to
do with your look it's just to do with
mental health issues and the thing to do
is to look at the root cause of those
problems
not to change the look of your face
i mean is there enough support then for
people who who feel like this we know
that we're going through a time of
difficulty in funding social care and of
course the nhs is there enough are there
enough professionals working in this
field that can actually address people's
concerns
well we do say that access to nhs
services has not been
as easy as it should be and of course
that's the case across the board because
of the uh the post covered backlog and
all sorts of other reasons but i think
our particular concern is actually that
in some ways access is too easy for
people who are feeling depressed uh or
anxious about their body image
they can go and get these procedures
done
you know on the spur at the moment
without proper consideration and then
they find out that it hasn't actually
solved the root problem which was
concerned about their body image and the
other thing we say in the report and
this is i think um
you know a big change in terms of our
overall way of thinking is that when we
look at school children
our focus to date has been very much on
whether they are overweight and we do
have a very big issue with obesity we're
one of the fattest nations in europe but
we need also to be looking at whether
people are underweight
and so what we recommend is annual
health and well-being checks for
children
in which people are underweight are
flagged just as much as people who are
overweight
okay uh thank you for that uh jeremy
hunt let me move on if i can and ask you
to put on your former foreign secretary
hat for a moment i just want you to
react to the news we had coming in
overnight of the
drone strike that killed him i'm an al
zawahiri
well no one's going to shed a tear for
this very evil man
but what i would say is this also sends
a very powerful signal to people who
have tended to underestimate the
strength of america and the west and
tended to say we're in decline and and
the future belongs to the china's and
the russians of this world and i think
what this shows is the technology at the
disposal of the united states and its
allies remains the most formidable of
any in the world
and in the end sometimes we take a while
to get our act together but in the end
the west will react when our values are
under threat
and do you think there are likely to be
reprisals to this killing
well um
you always run that risk but in the end
i think what we've learned from what's
happened in ukraine
is that
sometimes weakness
is a bigger provocation than strength
and our enemies people don't agree with
our way of life don't accept
our values
need to understand that the west is
going to be strong and resolute in the
face of challenges to our way of life
which is open societies respect for
human rights not marching into other
countries
and not setting off terrorist bombs
now this guy was killed in central kabul
does this just confirm for us that um we
can't trust what the talibans say they
were not meant to be harboring
terrorists
i'm afraid a lot of people will draw
that inference and i slightly draw that
inference as well i think that the
withdrawal from afghanistan was a very
big low point um for many many reasons
but this was the most important thing of
all we were supposed to be negotiating
that afghanistan would not go back to
being a harbor for terrorists i think
this indicates that
we can't be sure that's not the case